whoa Biden woof
[Music]
forgive him he knows not what he says
which wouldn't be a problem if he wasn't
our press
Biden's brain's obviously a little hazy
which is why he said that's kind of
crazy
Eddie Metals Factory they have them
there
President Joe Biden reminisced about
eating lunch with segregationists
amazing he still has the ability to
reminisce at all
we've always used to fight like hell and
even back in the old days when we had
real segregationists like Eastland and
Thurman and all those guys
but at least we end up eating lunch
together
things have changed we got to bring it
back yeah bring let's bring it back
[Music]
what are you talking about
good old days
I'm not sure what Joe was going for
there maybe he meant he misses being
able to talk with people even if you
disagree or maybe they installed a metal
plate in his brain while he was there I
don't know
Joe can you explain yourself no no no no
no look look we gotta get back to the
way things were the way they used to be
guys having lunch I mean not dinner
's not a good meal
but lunch I'm from Delaware I'm a lunch
guy I love lunch with anyone
not just segregationists you could be
the worst person in the world you could
be a a serial killer John Wayne Gacy I
bet the guy liked the sandwich
and uh you know Jeffrey Dahmer remember
he ate those people for dinner
hey you know uh lunch he was a soup and
salad Guy come on
cat
I hate playing the I hate playing the
what if it were a republican game but
what if a republican said yeah I used to
have lunch with segregationists all the
time we need to go back to that
yeah I don't think it'd go over so well
uh this I mean I guess that that was
what he was trying to say probably is
like sitting and talking with people I
disagree with but the problem there is
he also doesn't do that like he doesn't
even have lunch with camel no that yeah
he won't even have lunch with his own
vice president yes and I I you hear him
complain about it a lot he's like I'm
the unity guy yeah we all need to get
along but you never see him actually
living that no no because he actually
said that modern day Republicans were
you know some of the people that were in
the Civil Rights era racism right racist
he also Trump supporters of the most
radical criminal group in history forgot
the KKK and the fact that he went to a
funeral for a grand Cyclops from the KKK
forgot about that right and if I want to
have lunch with somebody I I don't do
that no you don't
you know uh Brett I made a an
interesting connection I found it that
like it's almost like that old school
segregationist and the modern woke
might get along better because they are
both about separatism like separate
graduation ceremonies separate learning
uh facilities separate classes that
would be interesting a school yes there
you go with both with both in there yes
I think when they go down the extreme
Maga which you're hearing that more and
more extreme Maga
um they've used that phrase numerous
times and they think I think they think
that it's politically beneficial but to
a lot of people I think it sounds like a
basket of deplorables right right or
like categorizing half of the country
that voted for the president and his
policies uh an interesting way extreme
maggot is a protein-rich chocolate drink
and then we come full circle right
that's an extreme bad guys
Greg I like the chocolate milk that's in
your face skunk
it Mountain Dew
I don't know where I am skunk
you're in New York with me
okay that's gonna be the assisted living
facility
hey we're all going to be there one of
these days oh God I'll be there before
you skunk
um yeah so what's what's your take on
the president I know that you you work
for the government so maybe you can't
say anything but well I I guess I have
to say I took an oath to defend the
Constitution I believe in the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights and
the Declaration of Independence and the
the the the documents that are the
foundation of our country so no matter
who the president is I took an oath to
to support
and I believe in the system and I think
long before whatever president is is
gone that the system will remain the
same and the fact that there are people
in the country on both sides by the way
that believe more in the principles than
they do in worrying about who is where
and who is doing what that's the only
thing that will keep this country moving
forward and keep this country alive
there you go yeah I don't think
[Applause]
but why you have this racist on
I like chocolate milk
and you too that's right uh I gotta say
that it must be really hard to be in the
White House yeah and just be a young
person and not just want to get Grandpa
going yeah you know what I mean I just
want to say hey uh Mr President what was
it like back when all the you know the
civil rights leaders were you were a
suit and tie well you know they were
much better off and just to see if you
could it's even get him to say something
he's not supposed to say you know like
get Grandma going a little bit like just
to see how it must be incredibly
incredibly tempting but of course I
don't think he's allowed out that much
no he's not I think that's the whole
thing about lunch and dinner I don't
think there's no I don't think they're
meal times there's like a it's a meal
followed by a series of pills I think
it's a which is what I do I was gonna
say how's that different from you I do
that without the meal I just jump right
into the pills I I think it's a can of
Ensure yes and then have a little walk
around and maybe a little emptying of
the and then that's that the chocolate
the chocolate ensure don't don't bit
moan it's a very good good thing so is
the Atkins chocolate is very good the
Dutch Chocolate quite tasty it's the
theme of the show it really is hot just
like you're such a successful person and
then you used to you paint this tragic
picture of your life it's just I just I
wish I'm just sending you better dream
bigger dreams
one of my biggest dream is to swim in a
river of chocolate milk
honestly you've had that dream yeah well
I bet when you wake up it's a mess like
but then I saw what happened to that
Augustus Gloop in uh in uh Charlie
Chocolate Factory yeah right all right
we got to move on we have one more
segment and it's great do you need more
than one pal to boost your overall
morale
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else